in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions
Michelle is with us hey Michelle how are
you I'm fantastic how are you Dave
better than I deserve
what's up I am here to do my debt-free
screen we're glad to have you and you're
from where I am from Chicago by way of
Detroit very cool well we're glad to
have you how much have you paid off I
paid off a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars excellent
and how long did that take you twenty
seven months wow that's impressive
thank you making what kind of money
about a hundred and sixty-five good deal
what do you do for a living I'm a sales
manager for an optics company you're
killing it I tried to congratulations
thank you very well done so what kind of
debt was a hundred and twenty thousand
so I'm gonna tell you the small stuff
first okay I had a car student loans and
then just random debt that I had never
paid off the big chunk was credit cards
Oh and in a sense that I paid him off
but I didn't really believe you so I
didn't cut him up mm-hmm
then I paid him off again and then I
didn't really believe you so I never cut
him up I pay them off three times before
I actually said I'm tired and I cut him
up oh gosh so it really wasn't $120,000
in debt except you kept doing it yes
gosh but the last time when you 27
months ago did you ever borrow again
after that done that was the end of it
and finally got disgusted yes and when
you get sick and tired of being sick and
tired that's when you change your life
yeah very cool Wow at that point you had
120 though yes and how much of that was
credit card debt before the repetitive
it was Molly no this is at the 27 month
mark when you started this 27 months ago
mm-hmm you didn't do any repetitive
after that right no okay how much the
credit card debt did you have at that
time when I first started is that what
you're asking it yes twenty-seven months
eighteen eighteen thousand yeah okay so
the other stuff all added up to a
hundred thousand so it was 18 and I
multiplied I did it three times so that
was about 50 and credit card total I got
you but that didn't all happen in 27
months now then it was the 30 for the
car the 20
I'm sorry 25 for the student loans there
for the car and then about ten of
randoms I got you okay
I'm catching on all right very cool very
cool yeah so really in the last twenty
seven months it wasn't it was more like
about 90 yes okay but but you did the
repetitive before that I got you that's
what I was trying to get my arms around
all right good
very cool so what happened 27 months ago
where you finally said that's it I'm
done
well I figure I make a good amount of
money you do and I didn't have anything
to show for it I mean I had things but
somebody else owned those things and it
was like well if something happens where
I lose my job or something goes wrong
what am I gonna do when I comes there a
moment though where you finally got
ultimately disgusted and turned the
corner yes I bought a condo before I got
into you mm-hm and I thought I've got
this condo and I can't furnish it unless
I use a credit card mm-hmm
and it was just frustrating check to
check I live check to check to check
very cool very cool
so you out you come in the condo there's
no furniture in it and you go this is it
we got a change yep and then what did
you do from that point what got you out
tell me your story overall I think it
was one of those things where I had a
mind shift like once I started to pay
things off and realize how much money I
had leftover it was like I could do more
than I ever imagined if I just took
control of my money okay all right a lot
of us in sales and I've been in sales
most of my life we try to out-earn our
stupidity yes and at some point you have
to stop and go nope I'm gonna get
control of this mm-hmm I'm gonna get my
arms around it well way to go way to go
very very very well done that is so fun
I have to tell you Dave I didn't get rid
of my dog though you didn't you kept the
dog what kind of dog is it it's a
Pomeranian named Cavanaugh that is great
so what advice do you have to someone
that's listening to us right now about
getting out of debt what do you tell
them the keys are when people hear
you've gotten out of debt don't give up
and just know that you may fail but it's
important to get back up and
again very cool well good for you
all right Michelle from Chicago a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars paid
off in 27 months making a hundred and
sixty-five a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
very well done that is fabulous
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you